deutschland steckt im winter shutdown
und die frage danach was jetzt
eigentlich noch okay ist und was nicht
ist unendlich moralisch aufgeladen
arbeiten schule und uni ja freunde sehen
live veranstaltung die der unterhaltung
dienen werden unter sorgt die maßnahmen
sind hart und notwendig bedeuten aber
derzeit kaum möglich feiern ist nicht
genauso wie café bar kneipe oder kino
filme sind noch schwierige jetzt als
single ja nicht nichts machen zu können
reisen geht ähnlich ohne die klamotten
an der schule sein geht mich genauso wie
studieren an der uni egal ob abeba
weltreise erst die woche oder hochzeit
abgesagt das jahr so wie es mir
vorgestellt habe finde ich gar nicht so
stadt irgendwie der abrieb ist also mit
einem fläschchen englisch deal
eingelassen ist einfach ohne familie
ohne freunde ganz klein in der turnhalle
und wer nach einem umzug versucht an
einer neuen stadt anzukommen wert seit
april wo nicht offiziell in mainz aber
behalten da ist man kann halt nicht
irgendwie dann 24 stunden alleine in der
wohnung sitzt viele haben kein nebenjob
mehr und andere sind seit monaten in
kurzarbeit
das schwierige für mich war es nach
diesen job jetzt gelernt
drei jahre lang und das ist einfach
traurig ein stück weit dass man diesen
job jetzt nicht ausüben darf nachdem man
die ausbildung nach drei jahren endlich
abgeschlossen hat und dann gerät der
kurzarbeit muss ist es schon leicht und
wie für alle geld viele haben keine
ahnung wie es weitergeht
wir verlangen den jungen leuten einiges
ab
also wir sagen ihr dürft nicht so leben
wie ihr eigentlich in eurer lebensweise
leben wollt und jetzt werden vielleicht
ein paar denken stellt euch meine ich so
an ihm hat es gibt ganz andere probleme
der pflege wirklich erkrankte in der
wirtschaft im gastro in der kultur bei
älteren menschen und so weiter und so
fort
aber es geht in der pandemie nicht darum
wer die größten probleme hat fast alle
jungen leute halten sich an die regeln
und wer dann doch mal sagen dass er
feiern vermisst der an wird ein
shitstorm dass man neben schule uni und
arbeit eben auch mal ausgelassen feiern
will oder alle seine freunde treffen als
luxusproblem dass ich das jetzt darf
sich das nicht werde ich sozusagen
geplant wenn ich das mache muss ich mich
dann unschuldig vielleicht fühlen und
jetzt kann man immer sagen aber wir
leben nun mal im westen sind
der soziologe michael kosten nennt das
ein leben in klammern ein leben auf dem
warte gleis die generation corona also
grob uns zwischen 18 und 30
die auf einmal in einer welt leben die
durch das virus durcheinander
geschüttelt wird und dabei geht eben
nicht nur um freizeit die wiro warnt
sogar vor einer lost generation sollte
es wieder zur schulschließung kommen
oder sollten schulschließungen in länder
wo die schule noch dicht sind länger
anhalten die pandemie trifft junge
erwachsene und jugendliche nämlich auf
einem ebenen viel stärker als andere und
deswegen ist es allerhöchste zeit dass
wir da mal genauer hinschauen
in diesem klub hier hinter mir habe ich
zehn jahre lang gefeiert und der zeit
lang sogar hinter der bar gearbeitet und
auch mir fehlt laute musik und feiern
und ausgelassen sein und alles was
dazugehört und der vorwurf junge
menschen würden rücksichtslos handeln
und wild feiern mehr denn viele studien
zeigen genau das gegenteil
die allermeisten jungen menschen in
deutschland verzichten bewusst und
verantwortungsvoll auf alles was jung
sein eigentlich ausmacht das meiste was
einem spaß macht außer zocken vielleicht
ist komplett anders oder fällt aus und
das aus rücksicht und sorge und andere
das schauen wir uns jetzt auf fünf
ebenen mal genauer an und starten mit
dem klassiker ausbildung
es gibt 10,9 millionen schülerinnen und
schüler und 2,9 millionen studierende in
deutschland und was schule angeht steht
fest dass fehlt an lehrkräften es fehlt
an räumen und es fehlt an digitaler
infrastruktur das einzige
flächendeckende konzept das über den
sommer entwickelt wurde ist lüften
das heißt zu hause bleiben abstand
halten und kontakte verringern es für
schülerinnen und schüler in der schule
oder zumindest auf dem weg dorthin
schwere die schulen sollen aber
unbedingt offen bleiben denn wenn sie
schließen bleibt das nicht ohne folgen
allein wenn man auf den lern zeitpunkt
hat sie sich im ersten block da und
durchschnittlich halbiert bei
schwächeren schülerinnen und schüler was
noch schlimmer
die haben sich einfach leichter ablenken
lassen eine studie über den lockt dann
in den niederlanden uhr zeigt dass die
schülerinnen und schüler im frühjahr
kaum was gelernt haben und die forscher
gehen davon aus dass es in ländern in
denen die digitale bildung noch weniger
fortgeschritten ist noch schlechter
aussieht als auch in deutschland
schätzungen zeigen geht ein drittel des
schuljahrs verloren bedeutet dass später
drei bis vier prozent weniger einkommen
und das sind jetzt alles nur
wirtschaftlicher oder zeit faktoren das
heißt wir haben noch gar nicht über die
psychischen und sozialen folgen
gesprochen
wenn das aber länger als 1 jahr
insgesamt wird dann müssen wir schon
genau hinschauen dann sind die
bildungsdefizite groß geworden aber auch
die entwicklungsdefizite an den
hochschulen und unis leicht das anders
aber das bedeutet nicht unbedingt besser
gerade für erstes ist es relativ schwer
reinzukommen
halt sehr lange aus studium geratet das
waren fast sechs jahre oder was man beim
konnten so die panini und dann geht es
irgendwie nicht weiter obwohl man
eigentlich also man nimmt das gar nicht
auch wahr dass man wirklich ins studiert
fehlende jetzt im ersten und im zweiten
semester sind hat noch gar keine
präsenzveranstaltung außer vielleicht
einer prüfung wenn ich dann mein erstes
semester denke ich wäre an der uni
verloren gewesen und auch in der stadt
dann ist man manchmal ziemlich
verzweifelt lernen niemanden kennen sind
zu hause vom laptop und 40 ein bisschen
hilflos deren von den hochschulen unis
und studierenden wird erwartet dass sie
das alles irgendwie hinbekommen bei den
beschlüssen der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sind sie
oft gar kein thema so seien zum beispiel
sagt durch ein bisschen routine wird es
im zweiten semester einfacher außerdem
veranstaltungen fehlt an der uni
natürlich auch partys feiern leute
kennenlernen hochschulgruppen
hochschulsport und natürlich auch die
bjp für ganz viele ist es schon auch ein
wichtiger teil ihrer tagesstruktur und
das macht das ganze auch ein stückweit
schwierig ich finds katastrophe also
soll die bürgerin eigentlich gewesen
ich hab das einfach brauche aus den
eigenen vier wänden herauszukommen um
produktiv zu sein weil ich zu hause
einfach viel zu viele sachen natürlich
abgeklärt
wer ein 450 euro nebenjob hatte bekommt
kein kurzarbeitergeld und die branchen
in denen viele studierenden arbeiten wie
die gastronomie leiden sehr unter den
beschränkungen
diese analyse zeigt dass mehr studie
jobs gesucht wurden gleichzeitig aber im
verhältnis zu anderen jobs das angebot
an studie jobs und praktika krass
gesunken ist
auch am arbeitsmarkt sind junge menschen
also stärker betroffen weil sie noch
nicht so fest im sattel sitzen mein
freund hat zum beispiel durch die panini
seinen job verloren eine freundin von
mir schon seit beginn in kurzarbeit und
ihr büro kann sich die mieten nicht mehr
leisten
kelly hat gerade seine ausbildung fertig
in der branche deren zukunft super
unsicher ist ein wir wären natürlich
noch mal irgendwie eine andere
ausbildung zu machen wasser war halt
nicht jetzt das wäre was man wirklich
will weil ich meinen beruf gewählt weil
es spaß macht also ein aus für traumjobs
und wunsch zu den gänge krone macht
pläne nicht nur unsicher sondern
unkalkulierbar und zwar insofern dass
die vorzeichen diese uns dich immer
wieder ändern können je nachdem wie das
anime geschehen wieder sozusagen etwas
dazwischen sonst wirtschaftlich trifft
es die junge generation experten zufolge
dreifach zum einen durch einen stärker
umkämpften arbeitsmarkt zum anderen dann
dort durch niedrige löhne und zum
dritten durch stärkere finanzielle
belastung wie zb höhere immobilienpreise
oder abgaben eine umfrage der eu hat
jetzt schon gezeigt dass junge menschen
am schlimmsten von der pandemie
betroffen sind zwei drittel haben
angegeben dass sie schon finanzielle
schwierigkeiten hatten
und so geht es unter umständen auch
weiterhin statistisch zeigt sich wer in
einer rezession ins berufsleben startet
verdient erst mal weniger und brach bis
zu zehn jahre und das gab wieder
aufzufüllen wir müssen uns einrichten
darauf dass ein erheblicher minderheit
von 20 bis 25 prozent eines jeden
jahrgang ist die wirtschaftlichen folgen
der korona pandemie wird tragen müssen
das bedeutet keinen ausbildungsplatz
kann den arbeitsplatz das bedeutet nicht
den schritt ins den ersten schritt ins
leben und führen zu können keine familie
gründen zu können kein eigenes einkommen
zur hand zu haben und das verunsichert
und führt natürlich nicht dazu dass man
nur noch
noch weitere restriktionen im
lebensablauf gerne hin ja jetzt ist man
eben nicht nur arbeitskraft oder
schülerin oder studenten sondern im
normalfall hat man auch noch ein leben
das ist irgendwie komisch dass das
einkaufen das einzige highlight ist
nicht rausgehen keine freunde treffen
nicht feiern kein vereinsleben kein
fitnessstudio auch hier treffen die
kontakt beschränkung und die sonstigen
maßnahmen die junge generation härter
das ist für kinder leichter
das ist für berufstätige erwachsene
irgendwie machbar für eine ältere
generation nennt man sogar völlig
unkompliziert weil sowieso schon
zurückgezogen lebt junge menschen haben
wir kontakte und mehr freunde
sie lernen im normalfall auch mehr
menschen kennen ab 25 nimmt
durchschnittlich etwa die zahl der
freundschaften ab der weg dahin ist aber
entscheidend und eigentlich finden der
jugend silber ist sozusagen im alter 30
da werden ganz viele kontakte aufgebaut
habe sagen da sucht man eben auch wo
möchte ich mich in der gesellschaft wo
möchte ich mich in der welt platzieren
wo möchte ich sein
das ist nicht verfügbar man hat einfach
andere bedürfnisse und so dinge wie
feiern fitnessstudios cafés und bars zu
vermissen ist ganz legitim
es ist nämlich die normalität und auch
als digital native vermisst man reale
kontakte und will einfach seine freunde
treffen und zwar egal ich hier und
deswegen stimmt leider so aigner als ich
das ist stimmt die aussage dass man als
jugendlicher ein recht auf feiern hat
und jetzt sehr diszipliniert darüber
nachdenken muss die dieses recht denn in
gronau zeiten ausgeübt werden kann
umgekehrt dass es auch so für manche
kann das dass man eben nicht so viel
feiern gehen kann und nicht so viel
verpassen kann eine entlastung sein
laut dieser studie gilt dass vor allen
dingen für menschen mit sozialen phobien
oder depressionen aber auch hier geld
das ist noch eine studie jedem einzelnen
kann es damit natürlich ganz anders
gehen andere leiden wiederum umso mehr
denn alles was an freizeitmöglichkeiten
an ausgelassenheit und damit eben auch
an ablenkung wegfällt bedeutet man muss
sich sehr viel stärker mit sich selbst
beschäftigen und das kann
unter umständen vor allen dingen für
personen die alleine leben oder derek
dinger sind anstrengend sein
jetzt ist ja auch so ein bisschen die
kuschel saison sage ich mal überall auf
sozialen medien sind pärchen mehr
vertreten sei manchmal und das ist schon
gewissermaßen respekteinflößend ich
glaube man muss da sehr gute
selbstfürsorge betreiben um nicht
umzukommen die ganzen themen ringsum
dating sich ausprobieren single sign-on
svww ii leicht zusammenziehen der
familie gründen unter umständen sogar
das erste kind bekommen sind jetzt alles
dinge die tendenziell eher junge
erwachsene oder jugendliche betreffen
kinder zum beispiel hat mir geschrieben
im lockdown wurde 20 prozent mehr und 25
prozent länger gechattet die meisten
singles mit denen ich jetzt gesprochen
hat sagen wirklich jemanden kennenlernen
haben sie aufs ende der pandemie
verschoben also auf wann auch immer und
auch hier ist klar es geht nicht darum
hier single schenk zu betreiben denn
während ein teil der singles eben sich
gerade besonders einsam fühlt geht es
anderen einfach sehr gut weil sie
besonders gut mit sich selbst klarkommen
und beides ist vollkommen okay also ist
nämlich auch ganz einfach so nur weil
man in einer beziehung ist heißt es
nicht dass wir nicht einsam sein kann
nach acht monaten im home office und
viel zu hause sein stellt man sich ich
bin auch ein bisschen einsam
bisher ist froh dass ich betone die die
hre letztlich in der wg wohnt der hat ja
automatisch mehr kontakte und die
beschränkung auf nur noch einen besuchs
haushalt sind hier wirklich auch schwer
umzusetzen
die regeln sind da einfach viel mehr für
familien gemacht glaubt das ist nochmals
auf der welt ist man wenigstens eine
freundin sehen möchte und ja also
während der hinsicht werden wenn es sich
an die regeln halten können
auch wenn ich natürlich verstehen dass
das total sinn macht aber für leute die
in der bildgebung ist es halt sehr sehr
schwer zu realisieren und wer jetzt noch
oder wieder bei seinen eltern wohnt der
vermisst vielleicht einfach dass er
macht rausgehen kann und seine freunde
draußen treffen seine privatsphäre oder
einfach mal seine ruhe mein musiklehrer
und der unterricht 17 teils zu hause
weil er eben in der schule nicht
unterrichten darf
und wenn man dann halt ich sage jetzt
mal drei mal vier mal am tag die
gleichen stück gehört und halt nebendran
zimmer sitzt dann weiß ich schon ja bei
uns für den job oder fürs studium eine
neue stadt gezogen ist hat er unter
umständen wirklich probleme anzukommen
und das dann halt auch noch gerade im
dental ich weiß nicht unbedingt darauf
aus hier in einen erfunden zu sein wenn
ich weiß ich habe zu hause im garten und
ich kann mich irgendwie mehr jetzt aus
dem studium noch geschäfte mal ablenken
und ich habe zu hause meine freundin
meine unterstützung freund und das hätte
ich nicht gehabt
tja und so bezahlt sie jetzt für eine
wohnung in der sie eigentlich kaum lebt
die wagen haben der belastung ist bei
jungen erwachsenen schon seit märz am
höchsten das zeigt dass pandemie
monitoring der uni erfurt ein
generationenkonflikt gibt es im moment
nicht wirklich aber man sollte trotzdem
nicht denselben fehler machen den man
zum teil bei der diskussion um upload
filter oder um den klimawandel gemacht
hat und die jungen menschen nicht ernst
nehmen ein autor der tour jugendstudie
waren zum beispiel der kampf gegen die
pandemie ist ein marathonlauf und die
solidarität der jugend sicher nicht
endlos der deshalb ist es besonders
wichtig den jungen leuten auch zuzuhören
ihre bedürfnisse wahrzunehmen und sie im
besten fall auch in die entscheidung in
die kommunikation direkt mit
einzubeziehen
dann muss man vielleicht auch mal
darüber nachdenken wie partys möglich
sein könnten kuchener konform oder
irgendeine form von sportveranstaltungen
mit ganz viel abstand draußen und
charles und so weiter sollte die
restriktion phase jetzt längere zeit
anhalten müssen wir über so etwas
nachdenken wenn wir nicht wollen dass
die jungen leute in die illegalität
gehen und dann heimlich partys feiern
und irgendwo das machen und dabei
tatsächlich sich selbst gefährden ja
vielleicht dass die umstrittene kampagne
der bundesregierung die uns als faule
waschbären als leute die einfach nur
rumgammeln oder als gamer feiert und als
besondere heldinnen als anfang gemeint
da keiner weiß wie es weitergeht und
wann vielleicht wieder ein
ausnahmezustand hinzu kommt oder wir
zurückkehren in die neue normalität
weist natürlich am ende auch niemand wie
es jetzt damit
ausgeht viele sind aber nicht mehr
ängstlich wie dem frühjahr sondern
frustriert und auch ich habe einfach
keinen bock mehr aber wie wirklich alle
mit denen ich gesprochen habe nehme ich
die maßnahmen sehr ernst ich weiß dass
sie notwendig sind und ich verstehe dass
wir dadurch müssen und mir ist sehr
bewusst dass es viele menschen
schlechter geht als mir sei es jetzt
hier in deutschland oder freundin von
mir in madrid oder in italien
trotzdem bin ich genervt und darf auch
genervt sein und was ich glaube ich alle
teile der gesellschaft einfach mal
wieder auf die fahne schreiben müssen
ist das ist hier nicht darum geht wer
jetzt am schlechtesten geht sondern dass
es legitim ist dass es ein zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten an
unterschiedlichsten stellen schlecht
geht und wir müssen ganz klar im kopf
haben dass die entscheidung die junge
menschen jetzt gerade treffen noch
auswirkungen auf zwei drittel ihres
lebens haben und das ist einfach mal
wieder ein bisschen im fokus tja und so
lange wie es wieder geht bleibt ja wohl
nichts anderes übrig als durch mein
zimmer zu tanzen
[Musik]
ich frage mich jetzt natürlich wie es
euch damit geht macht ihr euch sorgen um
eure zukunft oder um verwandte und
bekannte und freunde schreibt mir das
nochmal in die kommentare ob ich gerade
gut geht oder ob er einfach so wie ich
manchmal mit der gesamtsituation
unzufrieden seit falls ihr euch ein
bisschen einsam fühlt ich habe hier oben
im märz schon mal ein video gemacht wie
man mit der situation umgehen kann und
hier unten findet ihr die zoomin
playlist und wie immer freuen wir uns
wenn ihr verweigert